before we get started I want to give you
guys a warning if you're a pixel fan are
you Bonnie's phones and you can't handle
hearing some negatives about it I would
just go away from this video I am gonna
mention all the positives but there are
quite a bit of negatives not really is
Google's fault hey guys it's max with
Mac's tech and today I'm doing my review
of the pixel 3 XL now before we get into
the experience let's take a quick second
to talk about the specs and the price
this phone comes with the Snapdragon 805
processor which is kind of topic line
from Snapdragon it comes with 64
gigabytes of storage and 4 gigabytes of
RAM so 4 gigabytes of RAM sounds like a
very small amount but it is the same
amount of RAM as the iPhone 10s max
which costs $1100 but what that said
specs don't really matter right the
optimization matters much more well
that's where you are wrong that's where
I was really disappointed as far as
performance this thing scores worse than
a lot of other phones with the same
similar hardware and on top of that this
phone has really been plagued with a lot
of software glitches and bugs and stuff
like that one of them which I think we
have an experience has been RAM and
where people would you know have music
on go to another app BM your music app
closes and that probably is a limitation
of the 4 gigs of ram compared to
competition which comes with you know 6
or 8 gigs that can kind of make up for
that on top of that some people have
experienced extra notches popping up as
if one wasn't enough a glitchy
experience and the UI that's something
that I've dealt with some just so random
glitches and slowdowns and things like
that and even worse those of you guys
who use Android auto I've heard multiple
reports of Dadi are just not working
when you connect with it which doesn't
make sense because Google makes Android
auto Google makes the operating system
and now their flagship device that costs
$900 is not outputting audio as far as a
new software experience I honestly am
NOT a fan I don't like how the launcher
works I don't like you have to go up and
then kind of go up again and the
multitasking that they have which seems
kind of like a copy from the latest
iPhones it really is nowhere near as
good an iPhone I love being able to just
swipe quickly and get to whatever I need
and here we're swiping it does the slow
animation pops back up and then if you
want to go quickly you can its lagging
behind
and then going back the other way you
can you can only just scroll one way so
they're doing something similar but it
just is worse and it's slower all around
along with that for taking a selfie
photo that has to be processed after the
fact so you can't instantly see it and
if you take a panorama not only is it
very small in size about five megabytes
compared to 30 or 40 with an iPhone it
saves all the detail you have to wait
quite a bit sometimes up to a minute for
it to process and render when on other
phones it's almost instant now beating
out all of those things and the thing
that affected me most is photos not
being saved now I was out shooting some
comparisons for that blue insider
Channel and shooting some comparisons
from my own channel and then going
through the images I'm seeing images on
my iPhone that are not on the pixel and
I remember I absolutely took those
photos where are they and then it comes
out in the news different websites are
reporting that the pixel 3 is not saving
photos if you switch apps too quickly
before it has time to process and save
that is just crazy to have a flagship
device in almost 2019 that can't save
your photos all around it it's a very
nice look it feels kind of nice in the
hand but it doesn't have that same kind
of premium feel that you get with say an
iPhone 10s with that stainless steel
band and now let's talk about the front
of this device where we have this huge
knotch
we have this huge chin and why is it
even there with this notch right here if
you look at the actual front-facing
cameras they're quite low there's a
bunch of extra space between the frame
and the front-facing cameras and most
other companies that have notches don't
do that if they have a notch they fill
in that space and they don't just have
extra space for no reason now on top of
that the dual front-facing speakers if
we actually go ahead and cover this
speaker and some of the tests that I ran
the volume barely goes down most of the
volume is coming from this bottom a
speaker right here the same thing goes
with this large chin here one of the
benefits of OLED is that you don't need
backlighting meaning it's much easier to
do a display with really thin and small
bezels in a very small chin but they
have this very large chin here even
though the speaker is all the way down
next to the frame here so if we compare
it to
one plus 60 which cost less money so if
you look at the display it fills up
almost the whole phone the chin is very
minimal the notch is very minimal and
the speaker is right next to the frame
there now one big downside has been
really annoying to me personally is the
fact that if you turn up the volume
close to max or if you max it out you
get quite a bit of vibration from the
phone if you're holding it like this
you're watching a video the whole phone
is kind of shaking and vibrating and I
haven't really seen that with a lot of
other phones that get just as loud for
example the note 9 or the iPhone 10
iPhone 10's as far as battery life this
phone is about average it's nothing to
brag about overnight the battery drain
has been quite large I'm not sure what's
going on and I think there's some other
software updates that they said they're
gonna put out to kind of minimize that
but it does have a decent sized battery
and for most of you guys it's not going
to be an issue the pixel 3 did add in
wireless charging but unfortunately it
is quite slow unless you buy the $80
pixel stand which enables 10 watts of
charging now on top of that there's been
reports of this phone overheating when
it's wireless charging I don't know
what's wrong with the thermals if they
didn't design it well but people have
been placing this on a wireless charger
the one that comes with a pixel and then
it overheats it shuts down in the
morning it shut off the battery hasn't
been charged it up and you're kind of
out of luck so maybe that's why they're
not enabling 10 watt charging all around
and you have to buy the pixel stand but
even with the pixel stands people are
reporting overheating issues with the
phone and now let's touch on what I was
most excited about when I got my hands
on this phone and that is the camera now
I did a video going into detail on why I
don't think this is the best camera in a
smartphone you can check out that video
above it has a lot more details but to
give you a short version I think that
Google really put their focus on the
low-light capabilities of this phone and
it really shows the low-light is
fantastic both for portraits for selfies
the nitesite feature which unfortunately
still isn't released even though got
leaked everywhere and a lot of people
download it so you can use the nitesite
feature right now on your pixel 2 on
other phones but Google didn't
officially release it so that looks
awesome
the
portrait photos and low-light look great
Google did a great job but what I think
they didn't focus on they didn't really
improve at all is there kind of HDR
technology what really made the pixel to
really stand down and it would pushed
smartphone photography forward is that
HDR so if you compare that to now what
Apple started to offer their smart HDR
you look at some what some other brands
are doing all those other brands really
took a note of that they really stepped
up their game and I think a lot of them
are better now than the pixels at least
even like the oneplus which is kind of a
more budget device it is very close it
might not be better but it is very close
to what the pixel can do and the iPhone
is better you can maintain more details
in your shadows you can get more
highlights that are maintained instead
of blowing out the colors are more
natural they're more true to life yes I
have unlocked some contrasts at times
Apple did put out an update that added a
little bit of contrast and added some
kind of sharpening they fixed kind of
their beauty gate issues but you can
easily add a little bit more contrast
yourself versus the pixel which a lot of
times has too much contrast and it's
much harder to recover in details from
the shadows where a lot of the detail is
just pure black compared to having it in
the first place and adding in a little
bit of contrast after the fact now one
thing that really bugs him is his phone
and some of you guys might like this and
that's totally fine that's the fact that
a lot of the pictures are just too cool
with white balance or too blue the
iPhone sometimes it's too warm but if
you compare both of them the iPhone is
more true to life and the white objects
look more white or the color that they
were compared to the pixel which makes
them too blue and sometimes at night
even though it does a fantastic job of
over exaggerate the colors and Google
talked about this on stage where it will
kind of guess what the colors should be
and really kind of boosting it up now
one area where there's absolutely no
argument to be made is if you're
recording video do not abide the pixel 3
or the pixel 3 Excel the video quality
is horrendous if you compare it to the
iPhone it seems like something from
three maybe four years ago and then the
audio quality is even worse maybe one of
my first smartphones take a listen this
is an audio quality test of the iPhone
10 F max this is an audio quality test
of the pixel 3 I honestly don't know how
they manage to have audio that sounds
that that
add on top of that every other
smartphone that has a snapdragon 845
processor has 4k 60 recording and this
phone does not if you like to shoot
super slow-motion where a lot of other
phones have 1080p at 240 frames per
second or even with low resolutions 480
frames per second or even faster than
that
this phone cannot do if you want to
shoot 240 frames per second you have to
shoot at 720p so those are some big
limitations even worse the video quality
in general looks really really bad you
have not a lot of contrast lower details
you have these crazy compression
artifacts that show up even without kind
of zooming in and then if you decide to
zoom in on the video the results are
really bad take a look at this where the
building is kind of shifting sideways I
don't know what's going on it's not just
the fact that the video is compressed
too much if you look at the file size
the iPhone file is half the size of the
pixel threes file but the video quality
is so much better and if you walk around
with your phone while you're recording
you want some smooth footage if you
enable the digital stabilization it
crops in 25% so that further reduces the
quality of your video and all these
quality tests that I've showed you side
by side that is without the
stabilization so you get the best
quality so it gets even worse
and even though you crop in so much
which the iPhone does not the
stabilization still isn't as good as
with the iPhone 10s or the iPhone 10s
max so this is another area where it
seems like Google didn't put any of
their focus on they're focusing on the
night features and maybe something else
where they just kept the exact same
specs from the previous phone and they
didn't upgrade it even though it wasn't
good in the past and this is one area
that bugs me where a lot of high-end
tech reviewers say the pixel has the
best camera but they're not really
looking at an overall picture they're
looking at a few things and maybe
looking at some low-light shots or some
of them just say that out loud and don't
even show you any side by side shots and
if you look at the video there's
definitely no doubt that it is far from
the iPhone and even some other devices
like Samsung's and oneplus so to wrap
all this up this is the worst phone that
I've ever purchased now it's maybe not
the worst phone overall there's been
some really bad phones but if you look
at all the features
the things that it's kind of missing you
look at the design and this kind of look
here you look at the softer issues that
it's having for a Google phone that's
supposed to be well optimized if you
look at the amounts of RAM you look at
how much they're charging for an extra
sixty four gigabytes of storage the fact
that wireless charging is limited and
people are getting overheating you look
at the photo quality which is good
overall but some other phones are doing
better you look at the video quality and
then you look at the price tag of nine
hundred dollars or maybe a thousand
dollars it really makes us such a hard
phone to buy or to recommend to you guys
compared to other options on the market
the Samsung's
the LG's the oneplus like I said this
really put into perspective where you
have a much nicer looking design a more
premium feel you have 4k 60 recording
you have 1080 at 240 you have an
infinite print reader you have double
the storage and double the RAM for $580
and I know it comes with a case as well
compared to if you want to get 128 gig
of storage you're looking at thousand
dollars it really makes us hard to
recommend and if we look at all the
issues that are plaguing this phone it
is a big disappointment so as a final
statement I just want to say that I'm
sorry about all the bad things I had to
say about this phone I really feel bad
about it I don't think I've done a video
review in a long time we had so much
negative things to say about a product
but with all the downsides and glitches
and the issues and the limitations of
this phone and then you consider the
price point it really just does not make
sense the only thing I really impressed
me was the nighttime photos those were
great but other than that everything
else is really soso or kind of below
average for a very high price point
thank you guys for watching if you guys
want to see more videos like my review
on this phone the oneplus 60 which I'm
really really liking make sure you guys
hit that subscribe button enables
notifications this Ben max with Mac's
tech and I'll see you in the next video